turkey has reportedly targeted multiple
military sites in Northern Syria
controlled by the largely Kurdish Syrian
Democratic forces areas in raqqa
Province are believed to have been hit
by Turkish artillery and drone strikes
turkey has increased attacks on areas
controlled by Kurdish Fighters it blames
them for an explosion in Istanbul last
month the SDF says it has documented
about 70 attacks since turkey announced
its operation on November the 20th now
the SDF controls large parts of North
Eastern Syria highlighted on this map in
yellow turkish-backed Syrian groups are
in charge of some regions in the north
these can be seen in purple and green
the area in the Southeast also
highlighted in green is controlled by
other Syrian opposition forces supported
by the U.S the Syrian government
controls the rest well a spokesman for
the Turkish president says the
government will not stop targeting armed
groups special advisor Ibrahim Kalin
told resource the dark Kurdish Fighters
were exploiting their ties with the US
in the recent incident when the
terrorists attacked the civilians on
istickler Street which is the you know
the one of the kind of hard points uh
you know main points of Istanbul uh of
course we had to respond and our initial
response was to coordinate and conduct a
number of air operations and of course
depending on the Threat Level uh as
assessed by our intelligence and our
defense Ministry and other related
agencies we will go after this
terrorists whether from the air or from
the ground for us
any and all pkk pyd ypg
establishments elements
posts military points are legitimate
targets for us
whether they are uh in Western Syria or
in eastern Syria Northern Syria near the
border or far away from it they are
legitimate targets because they are
terrorist organizations and we go after
them to protect our border we don't
Target Russian or American soldiers or
military posts in Syria or anywhere else
pkk-p-yd ypg elements and we tell them
to stay away of course from those
elements you say pyd ypg is using at one
point American flag at another point the
regime flag to protect itself saying
that you see you cannot attack us
because there are Americans here you
cannot attack us because there are
regime forces here sometimes they do
this with the Russians less so recently
but in the past that I think shows the
extent to which pyd ypg is using their
alliance with the United States to
legitimate the Iran presence in Northern
Syria well let's get an update on the
situation on the ground with Cinemas who
joins us live AI from killis in southern
turkey and what's the latest you're
hearing about the Turkish strikes first
in Northern Syria
well fully the regular air strikes and
shelling targeting the SDF controlled
areas by the Turkish military continued
over the night as well according to
Syrian Observatory is soar two SCF
members were killed during a drone
attack by the Turks and one of them is
said to be a high rank leader within the
ypg pyd but there is nothing confirmed
yet and also we are hearing the pro SDF
media reporting that the Syrian
government has sent more reinforcements
towards kobane Island so the regular
shelling continues this is the situation
inside Northern Syria right now and what
about the ground operation that's
expected from Turkey into Northern Syria
we've been talking about that for a
number of days now any signs of the
operation starting soon
uh well fully for the Turkish
authorities it can happen at any time it
can happen like in an hour as a
presidential spokesperson Ibrahim Cullen
said last month it can happen within a
few days within a few hours no one knows
but speaking to Military and the Syrian
opposition forces on the ground they are
technically ready but they everybody is
waiting for an order from the president
who is officially the chief commander of
the Turkish Army so now everything is
everything is based on the diplomacy
table we are here we have heard last
week that Russia is trying to mediate a
talk between turkey and the Syrian
government it is not expected on the
leaders level but we are expecting a
foreign Ministry level meeting between
the two governments who have been a fois
for the last 10 years and the
intelligence level talks have been
already underway for the last three
years but as the elections in Turkey is
approach coaching which is scheduled for
mid-2023 a Turkish president rajab
aardon is expected to make a move in
order to normalize relations at least
partially with the Syrian government and
but no one expects a president Bashar
Assad and president
to give a picture like shaking hands
like erdogan had a last last week with
the Egyptian president
but a foreign Ministry level talks
around the way but we are hearing that
the Syrian government is taking it slow
and they do not want to deliver anything
on a silver Plateau to Turkish president
argon erdogan needs a normalization with
the Syrian government but also on the
other hand erdogan needs a ground
offensive in order to prove his nation
that the the Revenge of the Istanbul
bomb attack has been taken by the ypg
forces in Northern Syria thank you for
that live there in Kellis